consideremos ahora las unidades del
sistema métrico para volumen básicamente
como medimos el espacio que ocupa un
cuerpo en tres dimensiones la unidad
básica en el sistema métrico para
volumen es el litro el litro hay varias
maneras de visualizar un litro una de
ellas es si tienes un cubo
un cubo que mide 10 centímetros de
espesor 10 centímetros de ancho y 10
centímetros de altura entonces esta
cantidad de espacio el volumen que está
contenido dentro de este cubo es de
litro otra manera de visualizar un litro
sobre todo conectándolo con la vida
cotidiana son las botellas de refrescos
desechables son esas grandes botellas de
plástico o de pet para ser más precisos
que usualmente contienen 2 litros de
refresco aquí estoy haciendo mi mejor
esfuerzo para dibujar una botella como
estas usualmente son botellas que se
usan para vender refrescos agua mineral
agua pura y como mencionamos son
botellas de 2 litros así es que si tomas
la mitad estarás viendo un litro así es
que un litro estaría reflejado aquí en
la mitad del refresco en esta botella
eso corresponde a lo que mencionamos
aquí del contenido de un cubo de 10
centímetros de profundidad 10
centímetros de ancho y 10 centímetros de
alto
ahora para medir volúmenes a escalas más
pequeñas de un litro siempre podemos
usar los prefijos del sistema métrico
decimal de si sentí mil y sin embargo la
unidad más usual para medir volúmenes
pequeños es el
litro mili
litro y ya hemos visto que el prefijo
mili significa un milésimo es decir esto
es igual a un milésimo de 1
litro la milésima parte de un litro u
otra manera de ver esto es que un litro
es igual a mil mil mili
litros un litro es igual a mil
mililitros y si queremos visualizar cómo
se ve un mililitro ahora en vez de un
cubo que tiene aristas de 10 centímetros
imaginemos un cubo que tiene aristas de
un centímetro es decir un pequeño cubo
que tiene un centímetro de profundidad
por un centímetro de ancho por un
centímetro de alto ese es el tamaño de
un cubo que contiene un volumen de un
mililitro ahora si quieres pensar en las
cosas que se miden en mililitros podrías
pensar en las dosis de medicamentos una
cuchara pequeña de las que se usan para
café contiene de cuatro a cinco
mililitros así es que las dosis de
medicamentos están en mililitros o quizá
también pequeñas cantidades de
ingredientes en algunas recetas de
cocina si queremos ir a una escala mayor
al litro siempre podemos usar los
prefijos del sistema métrico podemos
usar de cali tro podemos usar hectolitro
pero el que es más típicamente usado es
el kilo litro kilo
litro y como bien sabemos el prefijo
kilo indica que un kilo litro equivale a
1000 litros y si quieres visualizar qué
tan grande es un kilo litro a lo mejor
no es tan grande como tú supones hagamos
un cubo pero en vez de que este cubo
tenga aristas de 10 centímetros vamos a
hacer ahora un cubo que tiene aristas de
un metro es decir vamos a tomar un cubo
que tiene un metro de profundidad
también de ancho y de alto tiene un
metro y un metro así es que este sería
el cubo que contiene un volumen de un
kilo litro y como te podrás imaginar el
kilo litro es una unidad que se utiliza
para medir volumen es sumamente grandes
como el volumen del agua en una piscina
por ejemplo